the new RTX 80 is launching tomorrow so
let's take a look at how fast this thing
really is we've already taken a look at
the 5090 and that definitely set the
tone for what to expect I mean this
generation is not looking like a massive
jump at all especially in terms of the
performance vers power curve it's maybe
the smallest jump we've seen in the last
decade as for the 5080 it's a $1,000 GPU
$200 less than the 480 but the same
price as the 480 super which launched a
little bit later on on for that you get
slightly more shaders slightly smaller
silicon process same vram capacity at 16
GB although it is higher bandwidth at
gddr 7 as a little refresher let's go
back to the 3080 and the 4080 and see
what kind of gains we were getting there
in the 12 games that I tested there was
quite a bit of variance anywhere from
96% down to 10% but on average the 4080
was a 36% generational leap as for the
new 80 that number is now 14 % in fact
it's 6% in stalker 2 5% in Black Ops 6
and just 4% in cyberp Punk at most I saw
a 23% uplift in f124 and 21% in the new
God of War if you thought these gains
were bad let's swap out the 4080 for the
4080 super after all the 80 is 1,000
bucks the 480 super was 1,000 bucks the
average Improvement now drops to just 9%
in some games the performance is
literally Al identical which just blows
my mind I have no idea how Nvidia
thought this was okay one good thing I
guess is that the new 5080 is actually
pretty low power in comparison to these
other cards uh the listed TDP has gone
up to 360 wats but it actually pulls way
lower than that on average I was seeing
273 watts in most cases this would be a
good thing but here it actually just
makes the 5080 look weak I would much
rather this be a full 320 watt card like
the 4080 super and at least see a bit
more performance the benefit of it being
a lower power GPU though does mean some
pretty good temperatures this Founders
Edition uses the exact same coer from
the 90 as far as I can see after 30
minutes at full load it was topping out
at just 65° on an Open Bench and that
was with higher than average power
drawer and a pretty warm room
temperature of 25° C so some of the
aftermarket Mammoth triple slot cards
I'd imagine will easily sit in the low
60s with this thing even being in a
closed case it's funny actually my VR
racing Sim behind me has a 4080 in it
and I was genuinely planning to upgrade
that to the new 80 but as you can now
see that would be completely pointless
if you're coming from something like a
3080 or under though it would be a
meaningful upgrade I mean you're
definitely getting some more frames
between a 3080 and a 5080 it's like 70%
uplift on average in some games you'll
see over double the performance while
seeing less power draw as well Black Ops
6 is a bit of a weird one there I did
retest that as well today even on the
4080 though it does seem to underperform
for some reason and for those wondering
80 versus 90 it's a $1,000 difference in
MSRP probably even more than that in the
real world and we're looking at a 50%
jump in frame rate on average but yeah
5080 man it is pretty disappointing for
a bit more context the past 80 tier gpus
like the 3080 and the 4080 they were
faster than the flagships of the
previous generation so 380 versus 28
80ti 4080 versus 3090 they cleared them
pretty easily this new 5080 though has
no chance of beating a 4090 even if you
go back as far as the 2080 the 1080 the
GTX 980 they were all faster than the
previous flagships here though I mean
this thing is looking more like a 5070
quick mention on dlss 4 multiframe gen
it's the new exclusive feature on these
gpus and it is very polarizing to say
the least I've seen some completely you
know varied opinions on this from you
know it's the future of gaming to never
mention it ever again in a review I'm
somewhere in the middle I tested it out
in my 90 review and actually I had a you
know better than expected experience the
additional smoothness gained for me far
outweighed the visual artifacting that I
was seeing most of the time being able
to go from 80 frames per second up to
240 250 frames per second is something
that I would look forward to switch
switching on in some games but then when
I went to use it on the 880 with the
exact same settings my experience was
far worse and that's because the
starting frame rate was much lower
instead of the starting frame rate being
like 75 80 frames per second on the 90
it was more like 50 55 FPS on the 580
and since the frame rate is lower that
means the time delay between frames is
greater which means more visual
artifacting and it also means greater
latency so yeah if your starting frame
rate is like 50 40 maybe even 30 FPS I
think that's going to be pretty
unbearable but if you give it an input
frame rate of like 80ish FPS you know
being able to boost up to that 250 260
FPS range with frame gen you can now
fully saturate a 4K 240 HZ monitor yeah
that is a nice little bonus feature it
is never something that I would
recommend for competitive games though
let's be totally clear about that I feel
like that just goes without saying I
know the frame rates look super enticing
but the frames are delayed most
importantly and introducing any chance
of like artifacting or ghosting is just
plainly a bad idea in that style of game
in those games just set everything to
the absolute lowest settings and if you
need more frames after that you can drop
your render resolution as well for
single player games though where I want
to load up the graphics maybe kick back
with a controller and just enjoy the
story yeah I don't find frame gen that
offensive just make sure that you're
feeding it an input frame rate I mean at
least above 60 frames per second I know
nvidia's marketing around it has also
been super aggressive which is not the
best but now the truth is out there so
we can all see it for what it is so if a
4080 super and a 80 are sitting on the
Shelf at the exact same price of course
you'll go with the 80 but what's more
likely to happen in the real world is
that the 4080 super is going to be a
little bit cheaper or maybe you'll be
able to find a used 4090 for a little
bit more and in those cases I would
prefer to go with those other two
options instead so yeah definitely not a
GPU that you'll just want to throw your
money at definitely consider your other
options